have you heard about the iPhone 6 it's
gonna be big four million pre-sales
already by the time you see this video I
think it'll have just come out I've got
one waiting for me at a undisclosed
location I can't get into how I got it
however Apple CEO Tim Cook had some
interesting stuff to tell Charlie Rose
about how Apple operates and why they're
not really interested in our data unlike
companies like Google and Yahoo etc
let's take a look we've taken a very
different view of this than a lot of
other companies have is I our view is
when we design a new service we try not
to collect data so we're not reading
your email we're not reading your
iMessage if the government laid a
subpoena on us to get your AI messages
we can't provide it it's encrypted and
we own the key okay so I think that's
kind of interesting because we don't we
talk we do all the NSA stuff and
everything the government is doing for
your information and these companies are
doing for all your information but he is
making a distinction that I don't think
most people think about they're giving
you the hardware Google Facebook etc
they need the data to make their profits
so should we give Apple a little credit
here for maybe not being that interested
in what they just want to give us the
[ __ ] the truth right they don't need it
yeah that's I'm sure if they needed it
they'd get it right that's what I when
he was saying that I that's what I was
thinking like yeah they really everyone
else has it we can get it from them yeah
if we needed it it's it's you've been
run through a spaghetti strainer a
hundred times before you hit the plate
you know so everyone's had a look at it
yeah it's not that big a deal to them
they don't need to debt and there's no
desperation sale tactic needed for their
product they don't need to track
anything they know if they just announce
it you show up out of nowhere yeah I
don't I don't cut them a lot of slack
just because it's still a huge
multi-billion dollar corporation but
saying we're the good guys because we're
not selling your data we're just
enslaving Chinese children to make our
products yeah you know there's still an
unethical immoral rapacious corporation
striving to take money
from the pockets of people for something
they don't actually need that is
manufactured by people who do not
benefit from yeah by the way I know
you're putting your money where your
mouth is because I see right before the
show that you have a Samsung so you're
not just talking [ __ ] you're buying what
your what your beliefs are I have a neo
dapper steampunk popping pocket let me
show that till we show the chain.i we
were at a party a couple weeks ago and I
took a picture
this man has his phone literally
attached to his body so you know it is
our current timepiece it well soon
enough there's gonna be an Apple watch
you won't have to worry about that yeah
exactly has Apple kind of become the
1984 commercial remember that commercial
they ran during the Super Bowl and they
you know that they were saying Microsoft
is this monolith that everyone is
obeying to and now it's like just as you
just said I mean all these iPhones are
sold before they even come out and
everyone sort of has it and yet and my
feeling is look I did order it already
and michaelia is I I'm in this game this
digital game that we're playing I need
to have the stuff that will allow me to
connect with people the proper way but
partly I don't like the the thing that
they represent the Macy's Day Parade is
a perfect example underdogs supposed to
be about this big to be on that dog and
he's gigantic he's the size of jetliner
and it's over your head and he's over
you you know and it's just one of those
things I started out as a great idea but
everything that gets inflated turns into
the opposite of itself bite-sized you
know you called the Macy's Day Parade we
have the Thanksgiving that was supposed
to be celebrated they're entirely
replaced with the corporate branding
boom so it is branding right have you
guys seen that commercial that Apple
does where it's this long it's like a
minute long commercial about everything
how the designs are all from Cupertino
and it's very pleasant and light and
they never address the you know on the
back of your iPhone it does say made in
China so it everything's about branding
right sure yeah yeah that's it I don't
need to do press yes that's true promise
this branding issue is brought to you
Rubin reported sharing game room